Uh,
verbs are among those variable words we saw in the intro to the series.
Each verb has a stem and a range of endings.
We'll dig into the components of those endings at the end of this video.
Okay.
The feature known as person gives away the conversational distance of the actor
from the speaker.
I am the first person.
You are the second person and somebody else,
he,
she or it is the third person.
Latin verbs had different endings for these three persons.
Amil Hamas.
You didn't even need a pronoun with the Bourbon.
Latin,
just these endings.
Romance verbs the work the same way.
Vulgar Latin Condo,
Ganja,
much like Katelyn Cantu,
Qantas,
and Italian Canto Canada.
Of course,
you can include the subject perhaps for emphasis to Qantas to Qantas decanters,
decanter certain languages in or not far from France,
the only major one being French requiring subject,
but this is an innovation,
French [inaudible] and not just shelter for icing.
The modern languages.
Also developed polite second person forms.
Qantas addresses you informally,
but to be polite languages like Portuguese,
Spanish and Italian.
Coopt content.
Other languages like French and Romanian use plural forms for the same purpose.
Okay.
First,
second and third person forms also exist in the plural moose.
This vulgar Latin verbs have unique endings for these two come Thomas
[inaudible] Canton.
Okay.
French rematch.
Emiliano Romaniello and a few other languages still require pronouns.
Yeah.
Politeness matters in the plural to to address a group of people politely.
Some languages use content.
Yeah.
French Romich and Romanian you's the second person,
plural verb,
to address one of you politely or a group of you in any way,
but the same isn't true of Spanish can Camtasia,
which is only an informal way of saying all of you seeing
bring back those nouns from last time.
Third person endings are the ones to use with them.
Singular with singular nouns.
Plurals with plural nouns,
so Elu Lupo content or [inaudible] content or maybe with a more fitting noun.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
verbs like I'm a contests have a content part,
a stem and a range of possible endings.
The stem doesn't stand alone.
Unlike an English comp needs an ending to be a usable word.
Verb endings come in pieces.
The first piece is the conjugation,
which is the grammatical group of verbs that if our belongs to these come in
four flavors.
Ah,
a e n what was originally a nothing value.
These are numbered first conjugation,
second conjugation,
third and fourth.
The verbs you've seen so far of our,
of the AF flavor,
the first conjugation,
these vowels in each conjugation are the verbs theme called it thematic vowel.
So contact has a stem,
meaning sing and a thematic.
Ah,
but it's not ready yet.
We need person in number endings,
which you've already learned.
We Build,
Qantas does for you sing.
Compare that to force conjugation.
Fin,
which is the stem with a thematic e.
So Feeney's means you finish.
Okay?
[inaudible] means,
see it has the thematic a.
So v days confess.
You seen that he or she sings.
Now,
what do you think the word for she sees was involved?
Your Latin
con content.
So what we see,
what about they see
if you went to site,
the verb conceptually,
but don't plan to name the subject.
Romance has an ending for that.
It's the infinitive
Omari Cantata.
Videira.
Finied.
I know I've been skipping that third conjugation with the zero thematic vow in
classical and vulgar Latin.
These often show up with an unstressed,
a like Decatur.
Unlike all the other infinitives.
The emphasis is on the stem,
not on the thematic val,
so it's Dj,
not the chair.
This robust system gets modified in many languages.
For instance,
Iberian languages merge that odd third conjugation into the second door to the
fourth,
the four conjugations and six person numbers are key components of the romance
verb system will begin layering tenses aspects and moods onto these components.